well our final guest is someone who is
at the center at the brexit drama and
what he decides to do and what he tells
mps to do could prove decisive so
joining us now is the Labour leader
Jeremy Corbyn thank you very much for
being on the show today thank you
now there are reports in the paper today
that I just want to start off with
saying that labour is preparing to whip
its MPs to support an amendment that
would actually allow Theresa Mays deal
to go through
on the condition that it's then put to a
public vote I mean is that right no
we're not supporting to resumés deal at
all because we think it's a blindfold
brexit which will actually do enormous
damage to our economy what our
conference discussed last year was the
question of having a referendum on
future relationship with Europe and what
we want to do is put forward our views
as well which are the five points we've
consistently put forward and indeed I'm
reaching out to MPs across all parties
to discuss those at the moment indeed
I've been to Europe to discuss those
with the EU and so we would then favour
a credible choice referendum after that
so how are you gonna make this happen
because we've been talking a lot about
the Peter Kyle amendment there's McGann
reports in the papers that this
amendment is something that labour could
back I had a very good discussion with
Phil Wilson and Peter Carr last week and
we went through what they're trying to
do which is make sure people do have a
say in the final decision and that
latter we agree with and support and
they are drafting an amendment which
will be tabled this week and we will
obviously decide on a whipping
arrangements but clearly we've had a
very good discussion with them but the
key thing is actually at resumes deal
has now been rejected twice by
Parliament's rumor is has it she's
bringing it back on Tuesday for a third
time if that fails a fourth time after
that this is ridiculous
this thing has been defeated
comprehensively and she has got to
recognize that we've got to do something
different therefore our proposals of a
customs union market access and
guaranteeing rights and environmental
and sim protections are I think the
credible ones that are serious and
that's what we're putting forward and
that's what I've as I said been to
Brussels to discuss these with Michel
Barnier and representatives of the
Commission and the parlor
so I just keep going back to this but it
does feel is that you know in the big
bricks that machination the the detail
of these amendments is really important
because it's where bricks that it's
being shaped so I can be whipping in
favor of the amendment if the amendment
is as I have just set out then yes we
will be supporting it but we obviously
got to see the wording of it and Peter
and Phil are discussing that we've had a
very good very constructive discussion
in relationship with them as indeed have
had constructive discussions with many
MPs from all parties one of the quotes
in today's papers really stood out for
me this is from and Peter Karl and this
is what he said of you in John McDonnell
and and your views around a second
referendum I've seen for myself how they
have moved from inquisitiveness to
enthusiasm so I'm enthusiastic about the
prospect of a second referendum now I
love the way puts that that's very
nicely yes we had a good discussion and
yes our conference voted on a
comprehensive motion which is about all
the issues right to Europe we actually
said our priority is to go to general
election but yes we do support the
principle so enthusiastic about a second
referendum why enthusiastic I'm
enthusiastic about getting a deal with
Europe which guarantees our future
trading relationship protects jobs and
industries in this country and I do
think I do think people should have a
choice on that because that feels quite
different doesn't it you enthusiastic
about getting a deal which would mean
leaving the EU the priority what do you
want you're not trying or Italy is the
priority is to make sure that we don't
crash out on the 29th of March the
priorities to protect jobs and
industries in this country the priority
is to make sure we have a future trading
relationship and a choice a real
credible choice that the people can make
on their future relationship with Europe
at the moment we're heading for a cliff
edge with all the problems that has for
industry all over the country you saw
the concerns of people in Ipswich what
were the choice being in a referendum
would it be remain or Teresa Mays deal
well the Parliament will obviously have
to decide on the contents we don't have
a referendum law in Britain so
governments can't just call referenda so
therefore that choice would be discussed
by Parliament but it would obviously
have to be a credible choice that's real
for both those that
to vote leave or did vote leave in 2016
as well as those that voted remain would
you vote to remain it depends what the
choice is in front of us if we've got a
a good deal in which we can have a
dynamic relationship with Europe which
is all the trading relations so on then
that might be a good way forward that
unites the country this has to be in
that you may make testily
it depends what the relationship is
we've agreed in the future that's why
I've put forward all along the whole
concept of a customs union with the
European Union which would give us a say
in our relationship in the future listen
these things are very very crucial of
what we do and that's why we are trying
to reach out to ensure that can be a
consensus which prevents a No Deal exit
and the disaster of this government's
strategy is they didn't reach out for
consensus in the first place they've run
down the clock and they continue running
down the clock hoping that they can
force them peace to support a deal that
clearly 2/3 of MPs don't want to support
well let's just talk about and okay
because I know obviously you're keen to
have a go at Theresa mail that's your
job isn't leader at the opposition but
I'm just keen to refocus on Labour's
position as well you're saying you're
reaching out to MPs you're writing to a
cross-party group aren't you including
some conservatives who are you writing
to well what we've done is we spoke to
those in what to call the Norway plus
group for Europe to point not group
we've had two informal discussions with
large numbers of MPs Kirsten Burr and
many others reach out all the time the
principal points we're putting forward
are what I call the five pillars of the
labour proposal which are the customs
union market access and protection of
rights and we think that's a basis for
discussion and negotiation interestingly
when we took these proposals to Brussels
they are alarmed of the way in which the
British government's operating and they
were interested in the basis on which
they could negotiate with us because
they do not want this country become you
have agreed to Teresa maze with what
they want to do is for MPS to back that
and we'll set that numerous times
they've agreed
Teresa Mays proposals and they now
recognize that these do not enjoy the
support of the majority
they've said numerous of times that this
is the deal that's on the table that and
I know but they've also said quite
clearly that we have a credible view
there that they would be prepared to
negotiate they will agree in extension
to 850 if there is something credible on
the table and that credible would be a
general election in Britain which I
think be a very good idea so the people
this country can decide who their
government's going to be on and also to
discuss a future relationship what we're
proposing is a serious relationship with
Europe so we don't end up doing
sweetheart deals the USA or becoming
some kind of offshore tax haven now you
mention there at the kind of Norway Plus
plan or common market 2.0 and as
something that you haven't discussions
on what are the differences between that
plan and Labour's plan no there's not
many but there are quite important one
that essentially Norway plus would mean
we would be taking but not contributing
to rules and agreements whereas our
proposal is for a dedicated customs
union with the EU which would obviously
give us negotiate it I mean the Norway
plan is aligning with EU rules you're
also talking about what you referred to
as dynamic and alignment within you'd
have to I was a strange word dynamic
alignment but what in reality it means
is that we would not allow any of our
rights and conditions to go below
European levels but we would want to go
above them for example I think people
should get full rights at work from day
one of their employment that is not an
evil rule we could do that nationally in
any event well the difference is that we
wouldn't have any say on the trade
relationship with norway norway plus but
with ours there would be a bespoke
customs union with the EU so there is a
very limited as well there's a good we
had a very good discussion with the
norway plus group and as i say i'm
reaching out because i want us to reach
a consensus which means that we do
protect jobs and trade with Europe we do
ensure that we have a serious and good
relationship with Europe and we don't do
what
Fox spent the first year or so doing
which is threatening Europe with all
kinds of sweetheart trade deals to
undercut Europe so could could you just
- could you end up supporting the corn
markets you want because they are very
similar there would have to be some
alterations - and that's why we've had a
good discussion with them it was a very
serious and very collegiate discussion I
mean I quite like the idea of Jeremy
Corbyn the scourge of the Conservative
Party having all these meetings with
conservative MPs right into concerns I
can be very polite to anybody
are there any Conservative MPs that you
particularly admire
well I suppose I've known Kenneth Clark
for so long and we've disagreed on so
many things for so long we actually
personally get along that cabinet
minister Ken Clark well you see I he and
I didn't get along at all well when he
was health secretary and issues like
that but I I do think that he's been
consistent what he says okay
now I just want to because I'm also
politics should not always be about some
dislikes and so on of people it's
perfectly possible that we construct a
relationship with somebody even if you
don't agree with them now I'm just
really trying to kind of get to the
heart of Labor's position when it comes
to brexit because we've spoken though
about a second referendum we've spoken
there about trying to get a good deal I
mean these are things that are so
different one of them involves leaving
the EU potentially and the other one
involves staying in the EU
so what's Labour's position is it is it
to leave EU or is it to stay in the EU a
manifesto said respect the result of the
referendum our conference motion said
respect result the referendum our
conference motion also said we want the
kind of relationship with the EU that
I've outlined our preference would be if
the government cannot get its deal
through Parliament then ought to be a
general election and indeed in any
normal situation a government that's
been so comprehensively defeated you'll
now be resigning and have a general so
your preference is to leave the EU
our preference is to recognise the
results the referendum and what does
that mean recognize a result I mean
everyone recognizes there was a majority
of the majority that voted no but labour
is unique amongst the parties in that we
are appealing to people who voted both
leave and remain because at the end of
the day
it's the social issues facing this
country the poverty the insecure work
the homelessness and the growing
inequality that are crucial that's what
brings people together do you want to
leave you I want to have a serious
relationship with the EU I would well no
I know it's not what you asked but what
I'm trying to help you say is that I am
trying to say is that we want to have a
relationship with the EU of the type I
set out and people will have a choice on
that but all the a credible choice in
any referendum that Labour process do
you want do you want to leave the EU
I've had many Chris's of the EU I
recognize many of the values of the EU I
want to see it more accountable and more
democratic and that's what was what I
campaigned for in the referendum but at
the end of the day it's about the
trading relationship and the jobs that's
so important I don't want to keep going
on about the point but do you think it's
quite important I don't think it's just
me who's confused so I think we can just
have a look we were talking earlier
about the film in in Ipswich and which
of course labor took from the
Conservatives very narrowly at the last
election I spoke to two women they're
not previously labour voters but they
battery last time they also voted to
leave in the referendum and this is what
they said when it comes to your views on
Europe he keeps changing his views I
think it's very confusing if there's
another election I'm not really sure who
I'd vote for I mean they were worried it
really that you'd suddenly switch to
backing a second referendum the party
conference wanted to support the
principle of the people having a choice
I'm the leader of the party I must
recognise what the party members and
supporters want to do and that is why we
are putting forward the proposals we are
and why we think there ought to be a
choice on how they carried out in the
future it's a bit of a issue for you
though isn't it electoral because really
your path to power is through leave
supporting constituency's we can just
have a quick look well illustrate that I
mean these are the top 20 labour target
seats for tea apologies I'm just been
told in my ear at labour target seats at
the election and if we can just color in
the ones that voted remain on leave so
the blue ones believe voting steams I
mean if you back a second referendum
you're going away the next election on
you know
what you'd have to recognize is that
within that there are people that voted
both leave and remain within the
majority that the Conservatives got and
and the minority vote the Labour got in
those constituencies surely what brings
people together is the kind of society
we want to be in the future and that
will be our message in the general
election about investment in left behind
communities about understanding why
people voted leave because they were so
angry that their communities seen no
investment no development and many
people relying on insecure work surely
it's the Socialists whose face in this
country that are so important and we
have to form our relationship with
Europe around that but that's gonna
matter what our relationship was is with
the EU is gonna make a huge difference
to all those incredibly important things
who does play about absolutely that's
why people voted remain and leave nobody
voted lose their job nobody voted to
have reduction in food standards nobody
voted to bring in chlorinated chicken
from the USA so you clearly keen to have
an election understandably and what are
you going to do to bring that about when
are you going to call a confidence
motion in our government we've had no
confidence motion already the government
is apparently going to bring its
proposals once again to Parliament this
week I suspect they'll be defeated again
the whole process they're doing is
running down the clock I think at that
point a confidence motion will be
appropriate I think at that point we
should say there has to be a general
election of the people of this country
can decide do they want a Labour
government investing in people's
communities
dealing with inequality injustice and
having a relationship with Europe that
protects jobs and guarantees our trade
for the future so when they lose as many
expect the third meaningful vote on
brakes well that's the time you think we
will obviously decide the exact moment
but quite obviously we don't have
confidence in this government's ability
and indeed Parliament doesn't because
this government has got the record for
the biggest defeats ever by a sitting
government in Parliament I mean one
thing that we perhaps do know after that
the chaotic votes last week is that it
looks likely that we're going to be
seeing an extension how long an
extension do you think could be except
the extension as being suggested is
until the end of June which is three
months it's tight but I think it's
possible to do what's necessary in that
time could you accept a longer
well longer extension has complications
legal complication concerning membership
of the EU and European elections and so
the impression I got from the EU was
that they were not keen on extending
beyond on June they would rather get it
sorted by the end of June that is they'd
rather get it sorted okay now while
we've got just came - we talked a lot
about brexit and but I'm keen to ask
about another couple of stories that
through the news recently as well and so
we know that a former British soldier is
there facing murder charges over the
killing of two people on the Bloody
Sunday I was back in 1972 and do you
think it's right that British soldiers
are facing these charges I think the law
must apply to everyone and I don't think
we should have statutes of limitation on
this obviously a fair and proper
judicial process must take place but
what happened in Bloody Sunday was awful
was appalling innocent people did die
and that is surely well the wholesale
inquiry explained I mean some people
could argue that there's a discrepancy
and because while there's more than two
hundred and Republican suspects who were
sent what's known as comfort letters
effectively telling them that they were
no longer wanted by police some would
describe that really as an amnesty and
yet British soldiers have been taken to
court is that fair this came out of the
North Island peace process there's
obviously a case against this this
soldier concerned and obviously a
process will have to take place but I do
think it's quite important to have the
independence of a legal process and
there has to be an insurance that
everyone has to abide by the law we both
do accept a discrepancy on all the Good
Friday Agreement was important was
seminal and was complicated but it does
not provide complete immunity for
everybody it was never intended to
okay and now just finally I'm also king
of course to talk about the terror
attack and that we've seen in New
Zealand a mule deputy leader Tom Watson
has been saying that social media
platforms failed the victims because of
course we saw the very widespread
uploading of the footage of the killings
and all that forms on the Internet
do you think he's right I think he's got
a very important point there but this
was the most disgraceful far-right
terrorist attack and many security
forces around the world have been
actually put it's slow to investigate
far-right extremism going right back to
Timothy McVeigh in the USA and more
recent attacks including a far-right
attack in my own constituency when Macra
molly was killed I think we've got to be
far more aware of the dangers and the
far-right tom is absolutely right that
the social media platforms which were
actually playing a video made by this
person who's now accused of murder quite
rightly accused him of murder all over
the world that surely has got to stop
is there anything that can be done on a
practical level
immediately those that controlled and
owned social media platforms should deal
with it straight away and stop these
things being broadcast but there brings
into the whole issue the question of
regulation of social media it was social
media and there's some very dark places
in social media is where this person was
apparently inhabiting with his far-right
extremist ideas which ends up with 50
wholly innocent people dead in
Christchurch and a fear in multi
multicultural communities all over the
world and these kind of far-right
extremists going to picture I went to my
mosque on Friday and we stood outside
and what we said was an attack on a
mosque an attack on a synagogue attack
on a church attack on a temple is
actually an attack on all of us we have
to come together as communities how
concerned are you about the impact of
the far-right one social media I think
it's quite serious I think far-right
extremism is very dangerous the only way
to deal with it is to say
simply the far-right who always search
for a minority to blame be the Jewish
people be the Muslim people be the
Bangladesh or any other any other group
of people don't offer solutions to
anything the only solutions we have to
people's issues and problems the great
issues facing this world climate change
and everything else is people coming
together and we mentioned Tom Watson
there and there's been quite a lot of
reports about Tom Watson setting up
group within the Labour Party to look at
policies going forward you met with him
recently you do welcome Ben doesn't I
welcome any discussion about party
policy and the way we go forward our
manifesto was groundbreaking in 2017
we're putting more detail into it of how
we'll develop our national education
service how we'll deal with issues of
poverty and investment in this country
and Tom wants to discuss these issues
with members of parliament that's
absolutely fine what I've also done is
set up a series of seminars for members
of the Shadow Cabinet and their front
bench teams to discuss with members of
select committees as well as the party
groups on particular areas how we take
forward those discussions John McDonald
is hosting economic roundtables all
around the country so we go to town like
Ipswich we have a roundtable we discuss
with people what the issues are facing
their country or their community so that
when we're in government we have a
national investment bank with local
investment bank so we end the appalling
regional disparities that exist in this
country we've got to invest equally and
fairly all across this country to give
people real hope in those communities
that have seen nothing since the
destruction of their industries during
the saturate years of the 80s so is
labour a happy family you know labour is
a very happy family because we're
absolutely determined to take the fight
to the Tories to get a society where we
actually do genuinely care for each
other we don't walk by on the other side
while people are sleeping rough on us
like our streets okay Jeremy Corbyn
thank you very much how much